[Música]
olá meu nome é marina ele e só do 5º ano
e hoje vou falar sobre influenciadores
digitais
quem são o que falam e como impacto na
sua vida
mas o que influenciará influenciar o
poder de mudar o dia de alguém ea força
de transmitir idéias é ser capaz de
fazer a diferença
os influenciadores fazem isso os
influenciadores podem ser diversas
pessoas de professores pais a pessoa que
você aprende com essa pessoa e você
copia não copia mais a ajuda com os
gestos dessa pessoa é seu influenciador
para digitalmente ou fisicamente agora
vou falar uma única de as principais
redes sociais que atingem hoje em dia 1º
você sabia que a maioria das pessoas que
têm o facebook
mesmo antes de saber de abrir o seu
mesmo antes de levantar da cama pega o
celular e abre o seu feed do facebook
cerca de 2 bilhões de usuários no mundo
o facebook tem e 120 milhões de usuários
no brasil 120 milhões é má é mais que a
metade do brasil inteiro nem sagra 30
milhões de usuários no brasil e no e
hoje em dia está sendo uma das uma das
principais redes sociais da web jet mais
de 100 milhões de atividades diárias
sendo um bilhão e meio de usuários no
mundo entre 13 e 34 anos
o youtube mais de 1 bilhão de usuários
no mundo
98 milhões de usuários no brasil e mais
de 300 horas de vídeos são bons são
enviadas por minuto por exemplo nesse
minuto estão sendo vierem enviadas 300
horas de vídeo
agora vou falar sobre a comunicação e
interação dos influenciadores na nossa
vida
a comunicação eles podem se comunicar
pela internet ou fisicamente pela
internet normalmente são por e redes
sociais que podem ser diversas c
deixaria seu filho escolher sozinho em
qual escola ele quer estudar mas porque
em qual escola porque hoje em dia a
internet é uma escola
os influenciadores são os alunos e os
seguidores são os alunos não os
influenciadores são os professores e os
seus seguidores são os alunos
e então quando você está deixando seu
filhos como escolher o conteúdo que quer
ver livremente pela internet você está
deixando com que ele aprenda qualquer
coisa mas você sabia que apenas 37% dos
pais se preocupam com a vida digital dos
filhos 38% conversam com ele com eles
sobre os perigos na internet e os
perigos na internet é um dos principais
assuntos da pauta dos dias de hoje 27
por cento verificou um histórico de
navegação para quem não sabe o histórico
de navegação é onde fica todo que você
pesquisou ultimamente tem jeitos de
apagar mas também tem jeito de recuperar
21% estão conectados às redes sociais
dos filhos
mas como assim conectados às redes
sociais sabem se o filho criou algum
algum perfil em alguma rede social sabem
os posts que seus filhos fazem sabem
sabem quem seus filhos seguem e quem
segue seu filho quem segue seus filhos
mas que tal que tal usar essa força de
influenciar para fazer um mundo melhor
por exemplo existem milhares de canais
no youtube
mas eu peguei um exemplo de do canal do
canal do felipe castanha área ele não é
voltado apenas para ciências e história
mas ele tem dois
o quadro que tem mais views no canal
dele é o nostalgia história e nostalgia
ciências depende de mim e de você de
vocês e de todos nós
nós queremos mesmo é se queremos um
mundo melhor vamos usar essa força de
influenciar para o bem
[Aplausos]